Roman Gutierrez says he stares at the
sky every day in search of signs of rain
he has lost nearly all of his soya bean
crops this year due to crippling drought
conditions affecting the South American
Nation
this year we needed 600 millimeters more
that's why we lost all the crops most of
us read the land which makes it
difficult to pay rent but inputs and
other items we need the extreme weather
conditions have also cost shortages of
grass grain and water severely impacting
the cattle of many of the farmers in the
area
these are the Argentine Pampas the heart
of Argentina's agricultural production
and drought is everywhere to be seen the
drought is having an impact all across
Argentina this is a field of corn and as
you can see it's dry and it's already
been lost producers are telling us that
because of the lack of water they have
started to notice different types of
insects insects that they tell us they
had never seen before in this part of
the country
the lack of rain is linked to the La
Nina climate phenomenon a cooling of the
equatorial Pacific that cuts rainfall in
parts of Argentina
but this time Farmers say the situation
is worse than ever
there are insects that we didn't see
before but also people stopped
controlling because it wasn't worth
fumigating as the crops were lost we see
more insects here because they have
nowhere else to eat
Argentina is struggling with a hundred
percent inflation rate in the past year
and a shortage of US Dollars agriculture
is a crucial supply of Revenue adding
billions of dollars of foreign currency
to the central bank
and economies say the severe drought
will likely complicate the economic
Outlook of the country even further 20
billion dollars of exports which in turn
implied A reduced in taking export taxes
so there is also a fiscal side we are in
the middle of a dollar shortage and this
can only deteriorate further Eldora
shortage putting more pressure on the
exchange rate so this is going to stress
both the the targets with the IMF so yes
it's going to be difficult a difficult
year for Argentina
experts also believe that the political
uncertainty of the upcoming presidential
elections later this year could increase
economic instability in the country but
right now Farmers like Roman Gutierrez
are just hoping for a little government
assistance and for rain to help him save
what is left of his produce Aires